If you don't mind,
you have a whole corpus
of work and there are,
we current seems in some sense one of
them being things are getting better in
ways that we really don't know.
What are you,
what if you could have what you wanted
with regards to the impact of your books,
what,
what would you want that impact
to be and also what do you think?
Like one of the things I've done on
Twitter recently because I'm trying to
figure out how to use Twitter,
is to tilt my tweets towards people like
human progress.org someone you site in
your introduction and people who are
purveying information while including
yourself by the way,
who are purveying information about
how much better things are getting.
And so what impact would you like to
have your books have and how do you see
that playing out psychologically,
politically and what do you think people
who are listening now say could do
practically to get the
good news out so to speak?
Yeah,
certainly intellectual life
should be more data driven.
I bet you shouldn't be allowed to say
talk about any reported trend based on an
event that happened
yesterday or this year.
Because trend means change over time and
in so many areas we really do have data
and if you're responsible
not to to a site those data,
particularly since they
have become increasingly
available through websites like
our world in data and cubit progress.
So I'd like to see a replacement
of ideological debate,
which so much of our,
our current debate is,
it's whether the right or
the left is more saintly,
moral,
uh,
praiseworthy,
correct.
And more,
uh,
well,
let's look at the data.
It's,
chances are that neither an off the
shelf position of the left nor an off the
shelf position and the right is
likely to have it all figured out.
No one is this,
the end or,
or infallible.
These ideologies go back to the,
to the French revolution and they're
unlikely to be the font of solutions to
complex problems.
Let's try to see what works,
what doesn't,
and come up with the mixture of what
is most likely to solve our problems.
Spoken like a true proponent
of the enlightenment.
Yeah,
I guess,
uh,
and stepping back even farther,
I would like to see a
greater integration of the,
um,
uh,
the,
the insights and mindset of the science
into social and cultural affairs.
As we talked about earlier
in the conversation.
This very ideas often met with horror.
Yeah.
Well you don't just,
the humanities types I suppose in some
sense aren't very happy with the idea of
that they'd have to learn statistics.
And I can I have a certain amount of
sympathy for that perspective button?
Well,
there is,
yes,
there is a,
uh,
a horror,
the expanding realm of a bad
number in data and a horror at the,
uh,
the thought that,
ideas about human nature from,
from science,
from evolutionary psychology,
from behavioral genetics,
from social and personality and cognitive
psychology might be brought to bear on
our understanding of society,
of justice,
of art,
literature and fiction.
Quite contrary to be the mindset of
the enlightenment where all of the
enlightenment philosophers off.
We're,
uh,
we're pretty serious psychologists.
It'd be the field didn't
exist at the time,
so they weren't called that.
But they,
uh,
mind the observations from,
from travelers of missionaries and
a and explorers out be ways of other
cultures.
They relied on their own
observations and common sense.
They tapped into what brain
science existed at the time.
So it's not a,
it's hardly a radical idea
that our understanding of,
uh,
of art and culture and society should be
informed by our understanding of human
nature.
But now that the disciplines have become
so professionalized and they're housed
in different buildings on
campus and there are rivals for,
uh,
money from the dean,
there's great hostility to
the old enlightenment idea
of consilience is often a,
a,
a paranoid fear that this means that
the sciences we'll take over the
humanities,
which of course is preposterous.
They wouldn't,
they would want to,
they couldn't there to be here.
No,
and I think the sciences can
really inform the humanities.
I mean,
my first side,
yeah,
I had to be trained as a scientist.
My appreciation for the humanities
is actually substantially deepened.
So in here
and indeed in many fields,
this is a authentic,
complete,
my,
one of my own fields of linguistics.
It's just taken for granted and no
one really cares where the humanities
influences.
I ended the scientific ones begin studies
of philology classical grammar of uh,
of texts now blend into
statistical studies of uh,
of Corpora,
of laboratory studies,
of speech and language processing and
where the science ends up in the ends off
in the humanities begins
no one even talks.
Yeah.
Oh the science can also really change,
can really change your mind.
Like I've looked at individual differences
in relationship to political belief
and so I've learned three things from
doing that that I think are revolutionary
had been revolutionary for me.
So the first is that
mmm,
liberal lefty types are characterized
by higher trade openness and lower
conscientiousness and then
conservatives the reverse.
And I think,
well that's quite interesting cause
it puts the liberal left types in the
creative entrepreneurial domain cause
that's characterized by high openness and
it puts the conservative types in the
managerial and administrative domain.
And so that implies that the liberal
left types create new ideas and new
enterprises including entrepreneurial
enterprises cause the doubted there is
fairly solid.
Where's the conservative types,
manage and administer those enterprises.
And so each needs the other.
And so there's that nice polarity dynamic.
And then there's also
the idea that the reason that openness
and conscientiousness unite to predict
political behavior is because of borders.
So open people like the borders between
concepts to be fluid so that there's
information exchange
and they're not orderly,
the liberal types because they're not
conscientious and so they don't see any
utility and keeping things
categorically distinct.
Whereas the conservatives are afraid of
the contamination of things because of
the movement of information and they like
to see the borders between things to,
to ensure that that's the case.
So the reason that openness
and conscientiousness stack
together as predictors
of political behavior
seems to be because of the,
I've two did fundamentally different
attitudes toward towards borders all the
way from the conceptual to the political.
So the right wingers think while
borders are good because that stops
contamination and is a real problem
and a definitely problem often.
And the liberal lefty type thing,
no,
no.
We want as much information
to flow as possible.
And both of those perspectives are
valid and need to be discussed.
Then the other thing I learned
from the American empirical doubt,
it was that orderliness,
which is part of conscious,
the part of conscientiousness predicts
conservatism is associated with disgust,
sensitivity,
and so that that feeds that desire to
maintain borders so that there's no cross
contamination that's associated with
what's being called the behavioral immune
system.
And so those are actually
quite revolutionary ideas
from the perspective of
political theory.
You know that the political belief is
temperamentally determined that the reason
that the two temperamental
traits determined political
belief is because of a
difference in attitude,
fundamental difference in attitude towards
the borders between things that you
can make a case for open and closed
borders on evolutionary grounds and that
there's a,
there's an association between
conservatism and discussed,
which to me shed tremendous light,
for example,
on the motivations of Hitler who is an
extraordinarily orderly person and who
use disgust oriented language.
It's all the time when he was formulating
his policies of extermination.
So those are revolutionary
contributions of individual,
different science to political theory
and it's all driven by hard data
statistically derived.
Well,
I,
I agree and I can sense the kind of
paranoid reaction that these claims might
elicit among some traditional
political theorist and thinkers that,
oh,
are you saying that the conservative
beliefs are nothing but an expression of
disgust,
sensitivity and of course
it doesn't apply that these,
uh,
big fascinating findings don't say that
the earned income tax credit is a good
or a bad idea or the Paris
climate accords by themselves.
I'd be issues still have to
be decided on their merits.
The other hand,
if you do,
if you are aware of your own potential
biases and that that is a source of
insight,
it's a source of understanding your cook.
It could cause you to step back from your
own convictions and be more receptive
to arguments on both sides.
Of course,
that was not for me,
that it can't not be a helpful,
cannot be an important source of insight
as to how political debates unfold.
Yeah.
Well if you know that the liberal left
types are necessary for the fostering of
new enterprises and the Conservatives
are necessary to run them,
then that certainly indicates why both
groups not only are necessary but are all
of mutual benefit.
Somebody has to maintain systems and
someone has to expand the and those things
are going to work in opposition to one
another because expanding a system often
fragments it.
So there's going to be tension but no
system can remain static forever and,
and,
and completely untrammeled transformation
throws everything into chaos.
So there obviously has to be a
dialogue between those two viewpoints.
Like a,
it's like an opponent
process issue essentially.
Yes.
And,
and uh,
all of us ought to be,
uh,
more aware,
have more insight into how our own psych,
psychological,
uh,
proclivities might,
affect the positions that seem to each
of us to be obvious to meet welding
and that is what they do.
Right.
Cause the temperamental variable
variables actually tell you what is self
evident.
That's how they operate.
Hmm.
My understanding from,
from the literature that
you're citing is that the,
the,
uh,
variance and opinions that is correlated
with an eight personality differences
is also the hardest to get people to,
to give out,
to,
to persuade them.
Yeah.
Well,
no doubt because I think the,
those temperamental differences
are like axiomatic values,
you know,
and,
and they're grounded and I think they're
grounded in the hyper development of
separate circuitry.
So it's going to be very,
very,
I mean,
and I also think that like if you're an x,
if you're an introvert,
you want to learn to be an extrovert.
You have to learn it.
Micro skill by micro skill,
right?
There's no revolution.
There is no revolutionary
cognitive transformation
that's going to turn you into
an extrovert.
You can pick up the skills,
but it's,
it's bit by bit it and it's incremental.
And so I think it's the same with
political attitudes is you can develop an
appreciation for the viewpoint of
people who are on the other side of the
temperamental divide.
But it's a,
it's an increment by increment
and bounce and it's very,
very effortful,
but necessary.
It's necessary.
You know,
it,
it's been really useful to me
to see where the cognitive,
sociological,
political utility of both
political temperaments lights and,
and,
and why it's so crucially important.
I mean,
with regards to discuss the sensitivity,
I mean you might think,
well that's pure reduct purely
reductionistic regards to the conservative
viewpoint.
But no,
a lot of people in history have died
as a consequence of cross cultural
contamination,
right?
I mean there are estimates that up to 90%,
maybe even 95% of the native Americans
perished because of their exposure to the
Spaniards.
Right.
And so the idea that
contamination is a problem when,
when two things that
were distinct unite is,
is,
is a truism and it's a
powerful evolutionary force.
An equally powerful is
the observation that well,
yeah,
despite that,
despite that though,
the benefit of information flow,
free information flow and trade is so
overwhelming that you can't throw the baby
out with them.
Water.
Yes.
It's a case where the
evolutionary adaptive value of a,
uh,
have a motive or a oven
emotion is explicable.
Uh,
and we can also recognize that thanks
to advances in science and technology,
the emotions themselves are no longer
particularly effective defenses against,
uh,
in this case infection by my packages.
We have much better ways
of protecting ourselves,
but we are stuck with these ancient,
uh,
adaptations,
which are,
are no longer whites who are
adaptive for the DB can be harmful,
especially when they're right to treat.
Other people on the metaphor
of contaminants are pathogens.
And you're certainly right that in,
in not in Hitler's rhetoric,
despite the fact that he is often,
uh,
claimed to have used eugenic ideas to
motivate a genocide against the Jews.
I'm much more of his language came from,
uh,
from pathology and Estonia.
Oh yeah.
It's contempt.
And
there was a enterocytes parasites.
Exactly.
Microbiology,
not genetics that daddy gave
him or is a toxic ideas.